our brain is the seat of our subjective
experience without a brain we wouldn't
be conscious of the world around us this
is what makes us us what allows us to
move think feel and plan and yet we have
very little idea about how the thing
works how can we optimize our brains if
we don't have a model of how they should
work
while no complete model of the brain
exists and although scientists are still
a long way from understanding its ins
and outs there are still an incredible
amount of things to learn
not least some new discoveries and ideas
that completely change the way we think
about our grey matter so keep watching
to get a better picture of just what's
going on inside your head and how to get
the most from it
so at its simplest level the brain works
like a little mind map our gray matter
is made up from roughly 86 billion
neurons neurons being brain cells there
are over 100 trillion connections
between those neurons which are known as
synapses the average neuron has a
whopping 7 000 connections to other
neurons on its own
this huge network which we can liken to
a mind map or a spider web is unique to
every single person and is sometimes
referred to as a connectome
in many senses you are your connectome
neurons are composed of a cell body or
soma with sprouting dendrites and axons
dendrites look like little tendrils that
reach out across the brain in order to
connect with other neurons the axons
meanwhile are the tails that protrude
from the cells
these connections or synapses between
neurons can be localized but in some
cases connections can span large
portions of the brain
some axons can be up to one meter long
synapses take the form of small gaps
across which signals can travel signals
meanwhile are actually electrical
impulses when a neuron fires which is
known as an action potential an
electrical impulse will travel down the
axon to the synaptic terminal at the end
this is the output port where the
electrical impulse will then jump across
to stimulate the dendrites of other
neurons
action potentials are binary that's to
say that a neuron is either firing or
not and there are no gradations of
intensity when a neuron receives enough
stimulation from incoming dendrites to
raise it above a certain threshold it
will then fire and carry the signal
onwards
in some cases input from one euro may be
enough to cause this in other cases
multiple inputs will be required to
depolarize the cell
there'll be then a brief cool off period
before the neuron can fire again
this electrical activity is what gives
rise to our subjective experience of the
world so when a neuron fires it will
correlate with an experience of an
action for instance there are specific
neurons that correlate to points within
our visual field so if you artificially
stimulate these neurons with an
electrode which can actually be achieved
during open brain surgery you'll see
points of light appear like pixels on a
monitor
other neurons correspond with motor
units that cause twitches within the
muscles
other neurons still combine to represent
our memories ideas and experiences for
example there will be a group of neurons
that represent our friends or a concept
like freedom
because of the interconnected nature of
neurons activity in one area will bring
to mind related concepts and ideas
giving rise to our train of thought
this alone raises some interesting
questions if you were to surgically
remove the right neurons could you
completely destroy someone's memory of a
specific person how many neurons would
that take this line of reasoning is
sometimes referred to as the grandmother
cell or jennifer aniston neuron
we know for example that brain damage
can in some cases result in shockingly
specific memory deficits for example
there are recorded examples of people
losing the names of all the vegetables
while being otherwise perfectly fine
[Music]
when a neuron fires in the occipital
lobe or visual cortex it's easy to
understand how this directly connects to
the eye and creates a solid experience
but how do we experience something like
the feeling of walking through the woods
or the number seven or loneliness what
is the brain translating this into
one leading theory that i particularly
like is that of embodied cognition this
theory suggests that all our experiences
ultimately relate back to the physical
experience and interactions we have with
the world
our thoughts would be too abstract to
mean anything without a grounded
experience in the real world so when
someone tells you a story about walking
through the woods you only understand
this by visualizing and feeling the
neurons that would fire if you were
walking through the woods yourself
abstract quantities like numbers
ultimately must also relate back to
physical experiences
while the brain might look like just a
giant web the truth is that it's
actually more organized than that
generally neurons are grouped by
function thus we have a visual cortex
and an auditory cortex which handle
precisely what you would expect more
abstract functions like forward planning
and emotion are largely handled by the
hippocampus and amygdala for example so
you have a different brain region of all
kinds of different tasks
the brain can also be roughly divided
into three larger components the
forebrain which is responsible for our
higher reasoning and is thought to have
evolved most recently the midbrain which
is the smallest part of the brain and
thought to act like a relay area for
auditory and visual information and the
hind brain which is the
primitive brain discounting the
cerebellum meaning the little brain
which helps us to coordinate movement
and may play an important role in our
ability to predict outcomes the hind
brain and midbrain are generally grouped
together as the brain stem
this part of the brain is responsible
for many of our most basic functions
such as breathing and digestion and most
of this occurs largely unconsciously
we can also divide the brain down the
middle into two halves called
hemispheres and these two halves are
then connected by a thick bundle of
nerves called the corpus callosum
but lest you think that the brain is
neatly organized into predictable
components the truth is a lot more
complex many functions rely on the
interaction of multiple brain regions at
once
as well as looking at individual brain
regions then neuroscientists are also
interested in common patterns of
activity throughout the brain which they
can analyze with things like fmri these
include the likes of the default mode
network a network of regions that work
together during daydreaming and the
salience network which correlates with
focus and attention
this is called functional connectivity
but even this is overly simplistic more
recent approaches use dynamic functional
connectivity to look at how different
brain regions interact over time
activity in one area might mean
something completely different if it is
immediately following on from an
activity in another area
not only that but in non-typical
development it's possible for functions
to migrate to entirely different parts
of the brain as in the case of people
who undergo hemispherectomies losing
half of their brain and still retain a
shocking amount of functionality
in your brain at any given time there'll
be countless neurons firing in these
different regions this activity is what
can be detected by an eeg or
electroencephalogram and this is where i
get our brain waves from contrary to
popular belief however we do not
experience a single type of brainwave at
any given time
one part of your brain might be in theta
while another is an alpha so when
someone tells you that your brain is in
the theta state either they don't know
what they're talking about or they're
really talking about the average
activity across the entire brain this
only tells a small part of the story
this is possibly where the misconception
that we only use part of our brain comes
from as well in truth we only use part
of our brains at any given time but this
is exactly as we would want it
too much activity across the entire
brain could result in a cascade of
uncontrolled electrical activity and
this is what happens in a seizure the
brain must be modeled to perfectly
manage the amount of activity so as to
eat out optimal performance without
triggering a neuronal avalanche dancing
on a knife edge this is called the
critical brain hypothesis
over activity in specific areas of the
brain can also cause issues like ocd or
anxiety whereas inactivity may correlate
with feelings of malaise or drowsiness
thus another important job for the brain
is to carefully manage these levels of
activity there are numerous mechanisms
in place to accomplish this
one such mechanism is smart organization
increasingly researchers are viewing the
brain as a maths problem and attempting
to model the kinds of networks that
would allow for complex thought
it's been suggested that this
organization is akin to a small world
topology meaning that neurons can
connect across great distances using the
minimal number of connections
physically this is made partly possible
by the silky and gairy the grooves and
bulges on the surface of the brain this
wrinkled appearance helps to fit more
brain into our skulls yes but it also
provides handy little shortcuts like
wormholes to connect disparate neurons
more fundamental are neurotransmitters
neurotransmitters are chemicals that are
released in the brain by various
mechanisms and modulate the activity of
neurons
neurotransmitters are stored at the ends
of axons at the synaptic terminals
located in the synaptic knobs and
contained within little sacs called
vesicles
during an action potential these
chemicals are released and will thus
affect the post-synaptic neurons those
neurons on the receiving end of the
synaptic gap
neurotransmitters include the likes of
dopamine neuroepinephrine serotonin and
gaba
each of these can be placed into one of
two categories excitatory
neurotransmitters that increase activity
and make our neurons more likely to fire
and inhibitory neurotransmitters that
decrease activity and firing hormones
can also act like neurotransmitters in
some cases
neurons are also used to kind of tag and
alter and experience they can make us
more likely to remember something they
can alter our mood
but as ever neurotransmitters are more
complicated than they're often given
credit for your brain is constantly
awash with a cocktail of different
neurochemicals you don't simply produce
more serotonin and then suddenly feel
better
for starters neurotransmitters also need
to interact with receptors in order to
have a direct effect on a specific
neuron so if a neuron doesn't have a
receptor for that specific
neurotransmitter it will have no effect
on it
different brain regions are more or less
receptive to specific neurotransmitters
or they might have different reactions
to them
neurotransmitters also have countless
different roles within the brain and
body for example cortisol is often
described as the stress hormone however
it's far more complex than that cortisol
also modulates hunger it helps us to
wake up and increases our focus
cortisol also affects the way that fat
is stored and the effect of testosterone
likewise serotonin is the feel-good
hormone but it is also inhibitory and
can thus incur drowsiness and this is
especially true as serotonin also
converts into melatonin which makes us
sleepy
likewise something called short term
plasticity shows us how the activity of
neurons is altered in the short term
so for example short term synaptic
depression occurs when specific
neurotransmitter vesicles are depleted
this results in a connection that is
less likely to fire in many cases
short-term synaptic facilitation
meanwhile occurs when a build-up of ca2
concentration among other factors makes
the synapse more active
temporarily increasing and decreasing
the sensitivity at specific points in
the network can drastically alter the
flow of information through the brain
and thus should be a critical component
of any attempt to model neuronal
activity
for all these reasons simply ingesting
supplements to increase one
neurotransmitter or another is not an
effective way to increase cognitive
performance as i've said many times this
is akin to trying to fix a watch with a
sledgehammer
and over time the brain can up regulate
or down regulate specific
neurotransmitter receptors in response
to what it sees as an overabundance or
lack of particular chemicals this is how
users develop tolerances and addictions
to mind altering substances
so instead we should focus on proper
nutrition to ensure that the brain is
able to synthesize all the
neurotransmitters it needs as it needs
them
along with a balanced lifestyle that
helps us to achieve the necessary
balance
the aim is to build a brain that can
transition seamlessly from one state to
another as the environment dictates
further complicating matters is
dendritic computation this refers to the
ability of dendrites themselves to carry
out basic maths this occurs through a
number of processes including the use of
membranous spines that protrude from the
dendrites like little branches and form
compartments these spines can connect to
individual axons and they can act like
filters by offering additional
resistance as well as spacing apart
different signals to introduce a
temporal element in other words a longer
spine might slow down the signal so it
arrives at slightly different time than
a signal from a different axon this way
dendrites themselves are able to alter
the effect of an incoming signal and
even carry out rudimentary logical
operations such as and or and zore
far from inert input nodes as they were
described by the old point neuron
hypothesis of the brain they act much
closer to the complex switches found in
microchips
[Music]
then there are the glial cells whereas
your gray matter is made from
neurotransmitters glial cells are the
white matter that actually make up 85
percent of the brain so they're probably
pretty important
these cells play a number of key
supporting roles though many of these
are still mysterious to us
supplying the neurons with nutrients and
cleaning up byproducts for example are
two things we know they do do
and we now think that glial cells may
also play an important role in enabling
action potentials and thus determining
which cells fire and which do not
there are numerous different types of
glial cells such as oligodendrocytes
astrocytes and microglia there are even
glio transmitters which are
neurotransmitters that interact
specifically with certain glial cells
and to think that most models of the
human brain don't even include glial
cells many don't include
neurotransmitters simply because we
don't know enough about them the brain
truly is a mystery to us
so so far we've painted a picture of a
static brain such a brain would be
largely useless however to survive we
must be able to adapt to our
surroundings and change our behavior and
approaches to this end the brain is
plastic and malleable constantly
transforming and changing shape in
response to inputs
this is brain plasticity or
neuroplasticity
through neuroplasticity we're able to
grow new connections between neurons
strengthen the existing connections that
we use most often and cull those we
don't need even birth entirely new
neurons this activity is more prolific
in some parts of the brain than in
others
the defining rule of neuroplasticity is
often described as neurons that fire
together wire together that is to say
that if two neurons are repeatedly
activated at the same time they'll reach
out over time and form a connection
through a process called long-term
potentiation
for example the axons might get
myelinated meaning they're better
insulated to carry the signal faster and
without damage
this is how habits can form and it's why
association works the way it does and
likewise neurons that fire apart wire
apart
these simple rules can give rise to
shocking organization throughout the
brain however for example the motor
cortexes of the brain are often remarked
upon for being organized in a way that
represents the shape of the body with
the neurons for the hands being located
near the neurons for the arms etc but
given some thought this makes sense
after all we're most likely to move in
that order we rarely move our hands
without also moving our arms and the
same goes for the foot in the leg leg in
the hip hip and the stomach this very
nice explanation comes from the brain
that changes itself
we can tap into this amazing plasticity
to learn any new skill however it can
also be a negative force for example one
of the reasons we find it so hard to
move our toes individually is that
they're so often welded together in our
shoes this literally fuses the neural
maps for the toes together such that we
can't move wanto without triggering
movement in the neighboring areas
neurotrophic factors are chemicals that
support the growth and health of both
developing and mature neurons these
include the likes of brain-derived
neurotrophic factor and nerve growth
factor and we can increase these via our
diet
our brains are most plastic when we're
young however and typically become less
plastic as we age but there are many
things we can do to slow the loss of
plasticity such as exercising and
gaining new experiences into old age
so there you have it that's a pretty
comprehensive crash course and how your
brain works i hope you learned something
new if you did please like and share
that helps me out more than you know and
subscribe too if you'd like to see more
like this
the main takeaway is that the brain is
impossibly complex and we are constantly
guilty of oversimplifying it we just do
not understand the vast majority of the
brain and we're going to see this theme
a lot more and some upcoming transhuman
themed posts i have planned
let me know if i missed anything in the
comments below and of course if you're
interested in optimizing both your
physical and cognitive performance then
you may be interested in my ebook and
training program super functional
training there's a link in the
description below
likewise i go into this in a lot of
depth in my print book functional
training and beyond either way thank you
so much for watching this one guys and
i'll catch you next time
bye for now